Charlie Graham had just left her mum's
house the place she feels most safe when
she was attacked by two men punched from
behind pushed to the ground then punched
again just five foot two with a small
frame she had no chance of defending
herself attacked from behind got punched
in the air pushing the floor and then
when I try to get up he pushes the floor
again grazed me knees we fierce and
company fears Ortman I've been jumped on
numerous occasions because I've been gay
and I've had things shouting others and
it is in this DNA justice course done in
a statement Northumbria Police said an
investigation has been launched into the
incident and officers are currently
treating the assault as a suspected hate
crime in May last year a similar attack
on a couple sparked similar shock and
anger Milania G Mona and Christine
Hannigan were abused on a bus in London
after the two women refused to kiss for
those harassing them they were punched
subjected to homophobic slurs and had a
bag stolen
and this homophobic hate crime is on the
rise in 2017 to 18 there were 11,000 592
recorded crimes in England and Wales
that number rose to more than 14,000 in
the last year an increase of 25% adding
to people's concern the number of
prosecutions for this crime is down some
research come out so more recently we
showed 81% of people aren't reporting
hate crimes
so I understand where that's coming from
because it does seem like we're
reporting them law but I think it's a
partly because there are more homophobic
attacks do you feel vulnerable when you
go out now I shouldn't I shouldn't feel
vulnerable I should be able to be Who I
am and why about the streets see if and
fails if I don't perhaps even more
shocking than these photos is this as
the fifth time Charlie has been attacked
a week on she's suffering with anxiety
and headaches but the fear she has when
she's alone could last far longer sally
Lockwood Sky News Sunderland